un anniversaire pour une partie du
territoire francilien la métropole du
grand paris fait sa quatrième année
d'existence une intercommunalité créé
pour rappel le 1er janvier 2016 pour en
parler nicolas landry bonsoir bonsoir
grégory de la rédaction de tv 70 buts on
en parle souvent de cette métropole du
grand paris qu'est ce qu'elle est
concrètement bay la métropole du grand
paris c'est d'abord un territoire
délimité autour de cent trente et une
communes regarder cette carte
cette collectivité composé de paris de
l'ensemble des villes des départements
de seine saint denis du val de marne et
des hauts de seine une commune au nord
dans le val d'oise et six communes au
sud dans l'essonne à l'origine de cette
organisation de loi votée en 2014 et
2015 la loi map tam pour au
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles et la loi notre la loi sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république
alors pour gouverner cet ensemble le
conseil de la métropole composé de 209
élus issus des conseils municipaux de
ces trente et une communes cinq
compétences vous allez les voir
s'afficher l'aménagement urbain le
développement économique social et
culturel la politique de l'habitat la
protection et la mise en valeur de
l'environnement ainsi que la gestion des
milieux aquatiques et prévention des
inondations
alors nicolas vous nous parlez de
seine-saint-denis du val-de-marne les
hauts-de-seine quel est le lien de cette
métropole avec les yvelines et bien
grégory
rappelez vous c'était il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine lors de la cérémonie des
voeux des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
à la scène musicale de boulogne
billancourt les présidents des deux
collectivités patrick devedjian pour les
hauts-de-seine et pierre bédier pour les
yvelines se sont montrés très critiques
à un vis-à-vis de la métropole du grand
paris et ont présenté leurs modèles
organisée autour des communes et des
départements écoutez les il pourrait y
avoir un bloc communautaire qui fait que
le jour où on élit ses conseillers
départementaux on peut aussi choisir un
système qui permettrait d'avoir des
conseillers communautaires par mais pas
des conseillers métropolitaine pardon
parmi ses conseillers départementaux de
façon à voir là le bloc métropolitaine
la région disparaît en tant que région
elle se transforme en métropole c'est à
dire que c'est elle qui aura la
responsabilité stratégique de
l'organisation du territoire
métropolitain
et avec en particulier tout ce qui
touche aux transports deuxièmement le
logement qui est une préoccupation très
prégnante à l'ile-de-france et
troisièmement les solidarités
territoriales
j'attends du gouvernement qui a déjà
fait transparaître son sentiment qu'il
règle la question de définitivement de
la métropole
en instituant le fait qu' elle recouvre
la région et non plus le périmètre
riquiqui de la petite couronne et
clivant alors grégory vous propose de
reprendre la carte du début et
d'appliquer cette proposition voilà le
modèle défendu par les deux présidents
une métropole à l'échelle de la région
ile de france
un conseil métropolitain composé de
conseillers départementaux 17
départements franciliens
c'est la proposition faite par pierre
bédier avec des compétences stratégiques
qu'il évoque les transports le logement
et la solidarité et ça pose la question
de l'avenir du conseil régional et de
ses élus qui pourraient être amenées à
disparaître du cou et à quel moment sera
tranchée l'avenir de cette métropole du
grand paris c'est bien grégory le
gouvernement pourrait trancher la
question de la métropole du grand paris
après les échéances municipales
peut-être qu'en profitant d'une réforme
plus globale sur la décentralisation
vous avez peut-être entendu parler d'une
concertation a lancé par le ministère de
la cohésion des territoires
elle est actuellement en cours jusqu'au
mois de mai 2020 objectif aboutir à un
projet de loi d'idées 3d pour
décentralisation différenciation et
déconcentration
merci nicolas pour ces précisions